- You're living in Australia now?
- I am.
- I love Australia,
it's literally my favorite place
outside of the United States.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
I love it, yeah, I feel
very lucky to be there.
- Yeah, and you're in Perth?
- [Kate] Yeah, Perth.
- That's the most remote place ever.
- It's literally the most
remote city in the world.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So good luck finding me, yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Don't challenge them,
don't challenge them.
- They're like "Hey."
- Well, congrats on the engagement.
How did you end up telling everybody?
- How did I end up telling, well, this is,
okay, so I--
- [Kelly] I heard it was an accident.
- I'm engaged to be married
to an Australian gentleman.
(audience awing)
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- [Kate] Isn't he gorgeous?
- [Kelly] He is.
- He's very handsome, he's very sweet,
he's the best.
So I did, I inadvertently
outed our engagement.
We kept it very quiet,
and I was doing an Instagram
Live with Amy Brennaman,
and he just came walking through the door,
in like a singlet, he'd just worked out.
I go "Oh, there he is now,
"the jungle cat himself,
my Aussie fiance."
And she's like, "You just outed him."
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- "You realize that?"
You know, when you're
on Instagram you think,
"Oh, we're just having
a chat with my lady,"
and you're like--
- Literally just did the
same thing with something.
Then you're like, "Oh my
God, it's live, we're live."
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- It's live, so it's done now.
- Yeah, it is, it's done.
You're like, "Oh, welcome," yeah.
- Totally said something I shouldn't have,
and I was like, "Well, whatever."
- Exactly.
(audience laughing)
- "You should be used to it by now."
- Yeah, exactly.
It must be what the universe wanted, so.
- What's, I like about--
(Kate laughing)